con unos folletos en la mano recorre las
calles de módena en el norte de Italia
soy candidato Al parlamento cuento con
usted de acuerdo no hay problema Gracias
Aquí es donde
está haciendo campaña sin parar eso
nació en Costa de Marfil y llegó a
Italia con 19 años en los últimos
tiempos se ha convertido en un líder
sindical un portavoz de los trabajadores
explotados una causa que lo erigió como
una de las figuras destacadas de la
izquierda italiana
habla de problemas reales la precariedad
laboral la explotación son las
preocupaciones que a nosotros la
generación más joven nos preocupa
constantemente y da voz a los
trabajadores explotados en el campo
personas
un tema que conoce bien porque también
ha trabajado como recolector de tomates
en los campos del sur de Italia una
experiencia que le hizo tomar conciencia
del destino de miles de trabajadores
agrícolas inmigrantes en la Península
he trabajado como cosechador en las
mismas condiciones duras desde el
amanecer hasta el anochecer
trabajando durante 12 o 13 horas al día
por una miseria absoluta viviendo en
condiciones inhumanas tuve que dormir en
la calle
una experiencia que le ha ayudado a
comprender el descontento de muchos
italianos que se sienten excluidos y
discriminados este grupo de estudiantes
acaba de presentarle una petición con
una lista de medidas de apoyo a los
jóvenes
Aquí vamos voy a firmar es el primer
político que ha aceptado firmar nuestra
petición es el primero que se ha tomado
el tiempo de escucharnos de entender
nuestras sugerencias no se trata de
ideología sino de cuestiones concretas
cuenta con el apoyo tanto de la
izquierda como del partido verde sus
prioridades la implantación de un
salario mínimo y la lucha contra la
explotación laboral un programa político
que espera contrarrestar la extrema
derecha en Italia